so as we now know the trailer that you
showed at the sony press conference is
just a playable teaser it's not part of
the full game not from what i understand
so i was wondering if you can tell us
what players can expect from the full
resident evil 7 it the conga I know is
so nice on the convoy so actually if you
take a look at the trailer that was
revealed at the sony press conference
and that's online now there are quite a
few images from the main game in there
so when you have a chance please take a
look and see if you can find some of
those and kind of going off that to the
demo that we have on the PlayStation
Network right now what's especially
created to focus on the atmosphere that
resident evil 7 will provide it doesn't
include a lot of other elements that are
in the game rather we wanted to convey
just what type of feeling you would get
from the game up in the actual game one
thing in those first and foremost at the
scale high scope of the game is much
bigger than the demonstration so he
feels that there's a lot more content
and a lot greater scope to look forward
to in the final game so you mentioned
that the full game will include sort of
more mechanics and this was really all
about atmosphere I was wondering you
comment on what some of those mechanics
might be for example what role will
combat play mean Resident Evil games
have always had some sort of gunplay in
them so I was curious what role combat
will play and sort of what other
gameplay mechanics will be included in
the full game so listening I don't go
hi-c Monday but one of the things you
would like to emphasize about this is
that it's not always about going in guns
blazing it might actually be the best be
to your advantage actually to try to run
away from combat at certain times or use
items to against your enemies in a
different way this is to say that you
know surviving trying to survive the
horrors vive ahora is a key element to
residence Evan so obviously this is a
pretty big departure from Resident Evil
6 the franchise has been moving more and
more in an action-oriented direction so
I was wondering why the decision to now
turned to horror and to what extent is
the game committed to her I mean how
empowered will players be by the end of
the game well they feel sort of
super-powered or where they always be
sort of threatened and scared throughout
the entire experience so yeah why the
returned [ __ ] and to what extent is the
entire experience [ __ ] it wasn't
someone on the skin of the mo it
addressing the first question why the
move to horror one of the main driving
factors was simply listened to the
desires of consumers consumers have
often told us very strongly very
passionately that they want to return to
horror so this is one of the main
driving factors also from a creative
standpoint it's kind of refreshing and
it's also easier to make a much more
kind of user friendly and easy to
understand game for the user if it's
more focused on that note you might know
that this year is a 20th anniversary of
Resident Evil and so you know as we
focused on the horror aspect for
resident evil 7 we conversely focused on
the shooting ax back for our game
umbrella core and so we feel that my
kind of being very focused on each of
these elements we can create different
games that are easy to understand for
the player and easy to get into so sort
of an obvious question I was just
curious how this game will tie into the
larger Resident Evil universe I mean
will we see anything from umbrella core
or Wesker Chris Redfield any of the
returning sort of characters or elements
that have you know defined the series of
all these years so where does this fit
into the series and how much will it
feel like a Resident Evil game going
kinda just somewhat jokingly one of the
things that we can tell you about the
only real thing that we could tell you
about right now is that there are herbs
in the game so that just gives you a
hint that there are resident evil
elements within this game one of the
reasons for setting aside for example
like the very famous characters and
things like that is to again focus on
the horror if you don't know what's
going to happen to you
or the person who you're taking the role
of in the game it's much scarier than if
you're kind of an iconic character who
you know is eventually going to make it
through the day and then also the story
itself to its hard to read what's going
to happen in the story because it's new
as compared to some of the organization
and things that you might know in the
past so we know that people understand
these enjoy these elements and there'll
be plenty of connections to those for
the player to enjoy but the story itself
and the action itself I think is totally
new and we hopefully it's much scarier
than something maybe perhaps um the
resident of experiences you've had in
the recent past so a bit of a two-part
question here so the first part is [ __ ]
games have enjoyed a bit of a
renaissance recently primarily in the
indie space you've seen a lot of smaller
titles like slender or at last or the
five nights at Freddy's a whole number
of horror games that have done really
welcoming from very small teams I was
curious if the resident evil developers
have been sort of paying attention to
those games or have been influenced by
them in any way or how they may be feel
about them and how that might impact
resident evils I had stuff who me um the
R&D team definitely plays these games
checks out to play many many different
types of games he hasn't played him
personally but he knows that the staff
has and they take them and take another
deep look at some of these and it's
actually part of the reason that gave
them that gave the team the confidence
to move to the first person perspective
is these independent games which have
proven that it is a viable perspective
for the genre or just for you know games
in general and not only the independent
games but no FPS has been a very common
game structure in the West for a long
time particularly compared to Japan so
looking at these success cases and and
also like just the way people have
constructed games around this
perspective gave them a lot of
confidence in the decision to move to
FPS so really easy to answer example of
what being a larger publisher provides
us is for example
the entire game supports VR so you know
only the backing of a large staff and
resources can probably make this happen
so that's a very easy example to speak
to from the production perspective but
interesting enough with this title one
of the main goals is actually not to
make a triple AAA game from the get-go
the goal is to make like the best be
ranked horror movie type of experience
or be ranked or game excuse me that we
could achieve the reason for this
thinking is that we don't want the
content of the game to be driven by
marketing which is often the case with
like a Triple A game instead we want to
be driven by the creator so in that
response it could be kind of even
something kind of weird in the game the
creator's think that this is
entertaining so taking the be the be
ranked route allows us to focus more on
horror and like an intimate experience
try to make that particular experience
as enjoyable as possible rather than
reaching for something that's kind of
more bombastic or by the line so to
speak so he feels like that although the
scale of capcom of course is much larger
than independent developer like to hope
that the the kind of spirit of the
individual developers working on the
title matches kind of the feeling they
have when they're creating their games
uh-huh so we understand that developer
Jordan tomorrow is working on this game
I was wondering if you could talk about
sort of the value that he's brought or
how pivotal his involvement has been
caused in tacchini she died was a
paradise maskin basically he thinks that
the crux of the question is whether or
not there are people who worked on the
PT a demonstration that konami released
and he could say that there are no staff
from on the team now or before that
worked on PT at capcom however we were
actually creating resident evil 7 before
PT was announced and so when we
announced it it was it was kind of like
oh they're doing FPS too however
now that we've come this far we can
obviously see that what the content of
this game is is completely different
from what the content or the direction
that that was moving in so I just wanted
to kind of make a point of that that you
know they're both horror or in the
horror genre but what you'll actually
see at the end of the day is complete
and he also knows from the hearing on
the back side of the industry in Japan
that the staff who worked on it I had to
work very hard to achieve what they did
and and he thinks it just it looked
really great and it had so much promise
and he himself was personally
disappointed that it didn't come to
fruition so that was too bad that that
happened the product but here just like
to share the fact that he really loved
it yeah okay hey Joe Oh Bob thank you
very much thank you so much appreciate
your time